là c'est ma fille ma belle-sœur des amis
un sac de couchage
Mandy va passer trois nuits ici pour
être au premier loge et elle a tout
prévu
l'adhésion des Britanniques envers la
royauté sérum surtout chez les plus
jeunes Alicia et Greg ne célébrons pas
le couronnement du roi ce week-end je me
fiche complètement de Charles la famille
royale aurait dû s'arrêter quand la
reine est morte
je ne crois pas qu'il soit à la hauteur
pour reproduire ce que la reine a fait
autant que je sache elle est restée
droite on ne l'a jamais vu faire un pas
de travers le roi Charles a un passé
plus détonnant
sera aujourd'hui notre cri du cœur vive
Charles III
qui va vers premier couronnement depuis
70 ans il n'allait pas louper ça
et alors quelque chose qui est tellement
britannique nous avons reçu nos
journalistes les portraits le
trombinoscope des chevaux donc ce sont
des Windsor Grey parce que vous avez
soit les chevaux baisse soit les chevaux
gris alors je peux les reconnaître par
leur petit nom je on a vu icon on a vu
milleford Haven alors ce logo officiel
il a été fait et imaginé par le designer
d'Apple maintenant à la retraite mais
c'est lui qui a tout fait il a fait
l'iPod il a fait l'iPhone l'iPad laïoli
enfin tout ce qui commence par un ail
regardez il est à côté du prince Charles
il nous salue
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable
seulement donc il n'y a pas des masses
d'endroits où ils peuvent venir camper
alors que pour Elisabeth dans 50 ans il
faisait plus de 8 km ce parcours et
pourquoi il est plus court pour la
sécurité
[Applaudissements]
ils sont en avance donc ils attendent
car il a été sacré d'abord par sa mère
on en a pas parlé encore
[Musique]
de toilettes a fait ce modèle réduit de
pots de chambre pour l'investiture du
prince de Galles en 1969
c'est le genre d'objet qui fait rire le
roi il adore l'humour absurde
ça gaz de ce contretemps parce que
évidemment il faut que toutes les
régaler normalement il les régalien
entre d'abord et il finit la procession
mais comme il est un peu en avance
il était très agacé cette image j'ai
fait le tour du monde voici un mug pour
le mariage de William et Kate elle a été
fabriquée en Chine quand je l'ai reçu je
n'y croyais pas je me suis aperçue que
c'était Harry et Kate en tout cas c'est
une belle pièce mais ils ont fait une
belle erreur
représente le mariage d'Harry et Mégane
mais comme vous le voyez ce n'est pas
Harry c'est Ed Sheeran c'est énorme
c'est quand même une image très
particulière très particulière de voir
le prince Harry
fiscalé du roi Charles III et même le
prince visiblement souriant mais seul la
masse commence
du Royaume de Dieu nous vous accueillons
au nom du Roi des rois
en son nom et selon son exemple je ne
suis pas venu pour être servi mais pour
servir
la nourriture pour chien spéciale
couronnement s'il vous plaît évidemment
le parfum c'est coronation chicken je
sais pas si ça coûte plus cher la pâtée
parce que il y a toujours un petit tu te
prime quand même
c'est des collectors
le manteau impérial mais aussi l'orbe le
sceptre à la colombe dans sa main gauche
le sceptre à la croix dans sa main
droite on appelle cela l'investiture
[Musique]
c'est quoi l'harmonie Julia
c'est presque ça c'est la première fois
que le roi Charles va apparaître sa
s'ouvre et voilà regardez vous le dites
et il s'exécute 14h25 heures de Londres
le roi est poli il était à peu près
ponctuel
Camilla pas très à l'aise
par la présence de sa famille ça a
toujours été important et le faste des
cérémonies est allé au fil des pages
laisse les habitants de ce quartier
populaire un peu amer
ce mauvais oui j'ai regardé hier
je ne suis pas vraiment mais c'est
beaucoup d'argent dépensé pour ça
on a tous payé pour le couronnement 6
euros moi mon père
ces gens-là ils ont assez d'argent il
n'y avait pas besoin de prendre le nôtre
pour leur fête
à plus de 60 000 déjeuners organisés
donc un peu partout dans le pays dont un
au 10 downingstrait dans la résidence du
Premier ministre Richer sunnac qui a
même joué les autres de luxe participant
lui-même vous le voyez à servir ses
convives parmi lesquels Jil Biden la
femme du président américain qui a
longuement échangé avec les personnes
présentes